[Musique]
avec vous là une frappe bien sûr bonjour
Alan bonjour Pauline elle a une de la
presse bien sûr l'arrivée en tête de
l'ex président de la gauche Lula au
premier tour de la présidentielle au
Brésil avec un peu plus de 48% des voix
talonner de près par le chef d'État
sortant d'extrême droite jaillir
bolsonaro qui est lui autour de 43%.
mais aucun des candidats n'ayant obtenu
plus de 50% des voix rendez-vous le 30
octobre prochain pour le second tour et
c'est ce qu'annonce matin il faut être
sympa qui voit dans ses résultats je
cite une polarisation de l'opinion entre
l'ex et l'actuel président du Brésil
d'après le journal le fait que j'ai un
bolsonaro est finalement décroché un
meilleur score qu'attendu prouve la
vigueur du bolsonarisme et mais l'ex
président Lola en position défensive
pour aborder le second tour riche
ination
de sa zone de confort se contenter de
faire semblant de demander l'amour des
électeurs semble insuffisant
en évoquant une vague bol scénariste de
grande ampleur certes pas de la même
ampleur qu'il y a 4 ans mais surprenante
pour qui se contenterait d'enregistrer
le rejet inspiré par JR bolsonaro le
quotidien ou glaube note toutefois que
l'actuel chef de l'État et bien elle est
le premier et la qualifier pour le
second tour avec moins de voix que son
adversaire depuis que la loi de 1997 a
autorisé les présidents à se représenter
pour un second mandat consécutif en
portugais dans le texte Hélène bravo à
vous la presse brésilienne qui exprime
dans l'ensemble un sentiment de
lassitude j'étais là on le voit présente
ses résultats comme le pire des
cauchemars malheureusement le second
tour verra s'affronter je cite deux des
pires candidats possibles reste à
espérer que l'un comme l'autre respecte
au moins les électeurs mais à en juger
par leur histoire c'est sans doute trop
espéré même face à un adversaire que
bolsonaro ce président qui méritait le
plus grand rejet de la part des
électeurs Lula le patron du Parti des
Travailleurs s'est montré incapable de
rallier une majorité autour de sa
candidature vu d'Espagne ces élections
donnent avoir un pays cassé divisé le
Brésil semblait prêt à refermer ses
plaies mais c'est une nation réellement
divisée regrette le quotidien et le pace
inquiet de ce qui peut se passer on l'a
évoqué d'ici le second tour avec un
bolsonaro qui va probablement continuer
à brandir ses insinations délirantes je
cite de fraude électorale et ces menaces
de coup d'état les plaies ouvertes du
Brésil évoquait également par ou pour
les coups qui est un journal portugais
il est tout aussi pessimiste avec un
second tour en vue et un bolsonaro qui
se relève avec un congrès ou c'est
légionnaires se trouvent renforcés on va
se profiler une campagne plus amère
encore et un futur plus incertain que
jamais
où va le Brésil et où va le Burkina Faso
théâtre ce vendredi d'un second coup
d'État Hélène en moins d'un an ne comme
en écho à cette actualité brésilienne le
site guinéen appelle l'armée burkinabé à
penser ses plaies les plaies ouvertes
par cette nouvelle parenthèse de force
un appel qui est également relayé par le
quotidien burkinabé le pays qui demande
à l'armée de rafistoler au plus vite les
déchirures internes provoquaient par ce
nouveau coup d'État militaire pour faire
échec notamment au groupe djihadiste le
quotidien burkinabé site ce proverbe
celui qui se noie peut s'accrocher des
expériment même à la queue d'un requin
et il demande aussi à ce que l'auteur de
ce nouveau putsch le capitaine Ibrahim
Traoré de jouer la carte de la prudence
sur la question
ultra-sensible du choix de la Russie
comme partenaire stratégique au
détriment de la France vu de France
précisément les manifestations prorus un
commissia Ouagadougou vendredi dernier
où l'on voit des
c'est en brandir le drapeau russe comme
les actions violentes à l'égard de Paris
sont perçus comme une nouvelle
manifestation des manœuvres du Kremlin
accusé par la Croix d'entretenir je cite
une vision paranoïaque de l'histoire
selon laquelle l'Occident chercherait à
instituer un système néocolonial ce
discours je cite lui permet de se
greffer sur un ressentiment latent à
travers le monde de nourrir la colère
contre la France au sein de population
déstabilisées par de des conflits
violents et nombreux dénoncent le
journal coup d'État sous influence russe
titre également ce matin le quotidien
Libération l'on voyait toujours hier des
habitants de la capitale brandir ce
drapeau russe le journal s'interroge en
particulier sur le rôle joué par
evegaini Prigogine qui est le chef de la
ministre russe militaire Wagner qui a
salué le coup d'État au Burkina Faso
pays pour lequel la Russie ne cache plus
son intérêt selon Libération la presse
française Hélène qui revient aussi sur
la rentrée parlementaire c'est
aujourd'hui en France cette nouvelle
session s'annonce sportive pour le camp
présidentiel qui ne dispose plus on
l'appelle que d'une majorité relative
l'opinion précise que les députés vont
entamer dès aujourd'hui la réforme de
l'assurance chômage le journal fait état
de la frustration de certains élus de
devoir siéger non-stop de ne pas pouvoir
l'ouvrir je cite mais aussi de jouer les
arbitres entre la France insoumise et le
rassemblement national et c'est le même
son de cloche du côté du Figaro qui
annonce une rentrée par le Nanterre sous
haute tension ambiance on ne se quitte
pas là-dessus Hélène histoire de vous
changer un peu les idées avant de vous
dire à tout à l'heure je vous invite à
acheter un silo gardien qui est fait
état d'une petite histoire assez
insolite l'arrivée d'une carte postale
au Pays-Bas 42 ans après son envoi je
crois que c'est un record et ça valait
réellement le coup d'attendre puisque
sur cette carte il est simplement écrit
méditation elle a été postée en 1980
depuis la petite ville de roven et elle
présente une sélection attrayante du
camping local y compris un petit panneau
indiquant l'emplacement du bloc de
douche ainsi que des toilettes et voilà
effectivement ça valait le coup
d'attendre merci beaucoup Hélène c'était
la revue de presse